evacuated from his home mr panayotis
watches his burning village on the news
he's lived there since the day he was
born and in his lifetime he's seen 97
summers
this is his hottest
the smoke completely surrounded us and
we couldn't breathe he says then they
brought us here
this former retirement home reopened as
an evacuation center on friday
last night alone 45 people streamed
through its doors
when we arrived there were a few rooms
available by the time we left they were
gone
many of those now needing this refuge
are distressed still in shock this woman
came to tell us it was british
firefighters who saved her house
i saw you and i said bless you she said
you came here to help greece but still a
huge catastrophe has happened here in
our village 28 houses burned counted one
by one almost all the olive groves
burned sheep burned goats burned
it's not just an international effort
here volunteers from as far away as
athens are staffing this evacuation
center others are sending supplies
with messages of support written on top
of food parcels the words courage and
hope
we need firefighters on the ground and
in the air as we are a difficult region
to get to but local businesses from all
the surrounding areas have instantly
come together to support us
21 villages were evacuated overnight in
this area of the peloponnese but around
lunchtime the conditions get too
dangerous and the roads are closed so
getting out is a race against the clock
people here at least now are safe and
for anyone who's lost their home the
greek government is offering 150 000
euros in compensation but for some
that's not enough and they've chosen to
stay in their evacuated villages
thinking they can somehow do something
to protect their property if they're
there in person and for many they're all
too aware this is a crisis greece could
be facing year after year
a grandfather brought here by worried
relatives is one of the last to secure a
room but he's among thousands in greece
displaced and distressed about what the
future holds sally lockwood sky news in
the peloponnese